coming up next on Star Talk Special
Edition all about heart
health what are we doing right what are
we doing wrong as a nation As the World
Turns out cardiovascular disease is the
number one killer of human beings in the
world today what can we do about it what
are the misconceptions how does it all
relate to coid and the vaccines given to
prevent us from dying and keep us out of
the hospital how do they all relate
coming up next on Star Talk
[Music]
this is Star Talk special edition got
with me my two favorite co-hosts in the
universe Chuck Nice Chuck how you doing
man what's happening Neil all right
longtime co-host comedian and actor Gary
O'Reilly former Soccer Pro Sports
commentator and we borrow him for this
because his life in heart is in soccer
but thank you Gary for giving of
yourself to us my pleasure thank you
Neil where you going to take us here
well recently say earlier this year 2023
we we did an explainer about the Demar
Hamlin NFL cardiac emergency that he had
on field and our audience came back with
a a variety of thoughts and ideas as to
what they thought had happened and it
made us realize because have a little
huddle as you do and you know what we
maybe don't know as much about the heart
one of the most vital organs in the body
as we think we should it is the number
one killer in the USA and I think really
we needed someone to shed a light on
that and so we brought back one of my
most favorite medical doctors Dr Lippy
Roy MD Lippy Roy great to see you again
uh internal medical physician public
health professional with the mayor's
office of Criminal Justice now whose
mayor is that uh so mock J the New York
City mayor's office of Criminal Justice
I believe was started during the
DeBlasio Administration gotcha got New
York City mayor's office um and you're
host of a YouTube show Health humor and
Harmony I love the alliteration and
you're you're often sought after
commentary commentator and we know why
uh MSNBC NBC News and Forbes uh you
write for Forbes and so so welcome back
to Star talk thank you NE I'm so happy
to be here and this is a topic that
matters so deeply to me so so we we're
told that there's certain foods out
there that are heart healthy and there
are heart healthy habits we can undergo
heart Healthy Lifestyles even
so issues related to our heart is the
number one killer of Americans yeah so
so what what are we not doing what
what's missing what what or maybe we are
doing the right things and you know who
was it that said eat well stay fit and
die anyway is this what's going to
happen regardless well that that is the
pessimistic approach but I but no it's
actually ail we have studies we have
data showing that if people adopted
these healthier Lifestyles or in other
words reduce their risk factors for
heart disease they will live longer at
least they won't die of heart disease
and to you to Gary's Point earlier the
leading cause of death globally is
cardiovascular diseases so so just a a
reminder that cardiovascular diseases
includes uh a group of illnesses
including coronary artery disease
um
cerebrovascular diseases um peripheral
artery disease which supplies the arms
and the legs Rheumatic you said cerebral
so your brain so why would your heart be
implicated by something that happens in
your brain that doesn't sound right
great question because because
cerebrovascular diseases means that
these are blood vessels supplying the
brain so the blood vessels are in are
come under the category of
cardiovascular dis oh so that's why the
heart is a wide swath of ailments as
describing it here gotcha well and
remember I'm not talking about the heart
I'm talking about cardiovascular
diseases so cardio's heart vascular is
your your circulatory veins veins and
things so combin I guess so stroke would
be cardiovascular is that right it it
it's exactly right so so a
cerebrovascular disease in includes most
commonly the stroke Strokes oh got it
got it very cool and cerebral vascular
disease sorry cardiovascular disease
also includes congenital heart disease
um and like when you're when you're baby
and I I already mentioned rheumatic
heart disease so yeah to the point that
we were talking about earlier it is the
leading cause of death around the globe
17.9 million people died of in 2019 and
the leading cause specifically 85% are
are dying from heart attacks and strokes
so to your your question Neil so yeah we
know what the risk factors are or maybe
people don't uh but they're not really
adopting all of it I really think it's
that most people don't know that the
leading causes are the risk factors are
it's smoking it's unhealthy diet it's
lack of physical activity it's being
overweight or obese and it's also
harmful alcohol consumption I well
that's it I'm dead I'm
dead well that's it it was nice knowing
you guys Chuck got more months it was
great yeah I got I got three minutes I
got are you kidding me doct is it is it
as simple as saying if we cure the
cardiovascular disease
scenarios we are now in the situation
where we can optimize our lifespan to
say 150 without there being too many
problems no you die at something else
you know like I know I want the doctor's
answer Not My
Thoughts well but in this particular
case our astrophysicist expert is right
because I I hate to be cynical I'm
almost always optimistic and positive
but in this case I mean look if we if
you're right Gary to your point if we
optimize and suppose we eliminate all
risk factors for heart disease right and
we are not dying of heart disease look
if we are lucky enough to live till 80s
90s uh somebody something else is going
to get us I bet no
caveman died of prostate cancer
right exactly they didn't live they only
liveed to
32 that's right 32 years old yeah great
prostate everything else failed this
longevity question is a it's not the
direct subject of this episode but it's
way more complex than just solving one
disease or another right yeah
yeah but you should keep in mind that um
you do live better so think of all the
people who are suffering from all of
these different ailments you know the
cardiovascular diseases um and heart
disease um if it if it isn't even the
big giant Widow Maker or whatever that
kills you you're not living well you
know you're you're you're suffering all
that time yeah and can I can I share a
personal story so so I'm of Indian
Heritage heart disease is a huge
epidemic amongst the Indian Community my
own father um was diagnosed he had a
heart attack in his late 60s uh you're T
totally atypical by Western Standard
heartbeat patient right lifetime
non-smoker thin active um very healthy
eater but he had a strong genetic
predisposition he had a heart attack in
his late 60s and then a very 20 years
later a common complication is heart
failure and to your point Chuck their
quality of life in the last year and a
half two years of my Dad's life he was
really struggling with heart failure
which slowed him down considerably this
is the same guy that went from India to
Europe to Canada drove to Florida one of
the most active guys I know he sadly uh
succumbed to heart failure in March of
this year oh sorry to hear that thank
you yeah no thank you but I mean but to
your point Chuck heart diseases if you
know it it can really impact one's
quality of life but if we don't die have
heart disease I just don't think we're
going to live till 150 Gary because
cancer Alzheimer's other neurologic
problems something else is gonna get us
I I that's my suspicion oh no I I
totally understand um I'm I'm just
wondering you know bearing in mind the
title of the show just how many
different ways does the heart get broken
does the cardiovascular system tie
itself in knots and just faile to
function one of the one one of the chief
ways is being a Jets fan
says the
eag just win they just be the Giants
right Chuck yeah well I'm an Eagles fan
so he doesn't care I don't care about gi
go go leave SK I don't even follow
football but I I know that just one but
yeah um well Gary to your point um
outside of um following um supporting
the wrong sports team there are other
actual causes of um or ways to attack
the heart look the most common one we
think of is coronary artery disease
right that's one that the heart vessel
the vessels that supply the heart they
get clogged or blocked right causing a
heart attack but there's also structural
heart disease so that means the blood
the the the vessel the the heart valves
the heart wall the heart chambers
they're all affected congener heart
disease um there's also aymas so like
vac viib these can all cause um so
there's all types of uh of ways to
attack or harm the heart um we discussed
there what happens internally how many
external scenarios affect the
cardiovascular system the heart I mean
is it is it as simple to say not many or
just about all of them well well great
question I mean I mean the heart is such
a fundamental organ I mean I love love
the heart it's so simple and yet
any one thing one aspect that goes wrong
everything shuts down everything slowly
deteriorates you can have something
acute right like a sudden Cardiac Arrest
but you could also have something more
chronic like the heart failure that I
described but to your point Gary
external causes like medications there
are tons of medications or drugs uh we
talked about alcohol um stimulants Like
Cocaine these can all adversely impact
the heart so there's a lot of other
external what about what about marijuana
marijuana he thinks Chuck's got to know
the
marijuana everybody knows cocaine's bad
for your heart but what about marijuana
I think I don't know specifically chuck
if um cannabis uh affects the heart
cannabis is one of those substances that
affects every organ but uh I'll have to
get back to on that cannabis is I'm
gonna take that as you're saying it's
absolutely
safe that is not what I said but go
ahead I love that you CL IFI but that is
not what I totally add actually
marijuana can make the heartbeat faster
and can actually increased blood
pressure which can actually harm the
heart but can I just go back to alcohol
Al I mean people associate alcohol with
the liver but actually alcohol can cause
cardiomyopathy it can elevate your heart
blood pressure it can really attack the
heart in many ways and it's it's a big
issue now because with coid alcohol
consumption has gone up in women and
alcohol rated mortality has gone up in
women so look as a woman and an
addiction doctor as an internal medicine
and primary care doctor this really
matters to me so so yeah one of the big
surprises during coid that um liquor
store sales went up uh pitously that
entire
time because that's when they started
delivering yeah so you can so it seems
Seems like you can track the health of a
country by the runs on the liquor stores
I mean I don't mean to laugh but just
without even without even testing the
people you can get a first cut at the
health by how many cigarettes are sold
how much alcohol is purchased just at
the point of sale right well it's it's
also a heart I'm actually glad that
liquor stores were open from a harm
reduction lens because if you cut off
abruptly cut off a person's alcohol
Supply somebody say who drinks regularly
you're going to put them into a cute
withdrawal and that's a medical
emergency that means the hospital is
going to see more more of these patients
coming in so from a harm reduction
standpoint I'm glad that liquor stores
were actually open but you're right you
are my kind of
doctor but to Neil's point he's right
that we did see a rise in alcohol
consumption cigarettes all that stuff
which is a sign of increased stress
right and stressors which of course we
saw with the pandemic right no now what
about the because you I think the the
amateur person the uninformed person
uses these terms interchangeably but if
you could detail for us like you may
have done this the last time but I I
can't hear this too often um what's the
difference between a heart attack
cardiac arrest and heart failure those
are different things right yeah and I'm
so glad you're you're right uh Neil I
remember in med school and resid
training repetition is the key right you
always repeat the same thing and people
confuse these Concepts all the time so
let's start with with Cardiac Arrest
very simply it's the heart and it stops
heart just stops many different reasons
but the leading cause is a heart attack
and a heart attack uh or myocardial
inunction um the blood go heart attack
on that one yeah yeah it's Mi but heart
attack so but the leading cause of heart
attack is or a heart attack is when the
coronary arteries or the vessels that
supply the heart get blocked there's a
plaque so that's a heart attack heart
attack means the heart stops because the
blood vessels supplying it get blocked
um and then uh what was the third the
heart failure wait wa wa wait wait wait
wait wait just to be clear vessels are
getting blocked constraining blood flow
correct if you're undergoing that a
person can walk around and say I think
I'm having a heart attack correct
whereas if they actually had a cardiac
arrest they're on the floor yeah almost
all causes usually Cardiac Arrest is
usually a sudden thing right so it
you're you you're dropping you're
unconscious right that doesn't mean you
die but it can mean that's what that
means heart stops immedately heart
attack to your point Neil you're right
people almost always have symptoms
indicating because it's a slower process
it could be fast but it could also be
slower so that means that part of the
heart muscle is no longer getting
nutrients specifically oxygen so it's
starts to die in myocardial infarction
means death of that heart muscle and at
that third distinction Neil you failure
yeah so that means that that's just
again a general term where the heart
just isn't pumping strong enough again a
lot of causes the primary cause for
heart faure being a coronary artery
disease or heart heart disease yeah and
what about the the uh what they call
apib can you just describe that to me
yeah yeah so that so again another
category for um what attacks the heart
or a form of heart disease is really
what we call aymas and one of the most
common arhythmia or a heart rhythm
abnormality is atrial fibrillation or
aib so you know there's different
chambers of the heart the atrium um that
Atrium what it starts to kind of not
have a regular rhythm but it kind of U
what call fibrillation yeah well there's
a flutter and then there's a a
fibrillation actually differ flutter is
a is a formal term atrial flutter
absolutely right so so if you say my
heart was a flutter it means you're
about to die oh look at
that you're a cheerful soul today Neil
you really are in a cheerful mood aren't
you we romanticize the heart and so many
ways don't we a broken heart a heart is
a
flutter but it yeah I'll we I'll be the
medical geek here and say that a flutter
can I tell you that an atrial flutter a
flutter your heart rate so what's the
normal heart rate do you guys know yeah
well mine is
65 which is with in normal range so
normal range is from 60 to 100 can I
tell you patients with a flutter their
heart rate can go up to the 200s wow it
is a absolute medical emergency they
need to get I thought that was uh teac
cardia um so Tac cardia chck great great
point is anything above a heart rate
above 100 so T cardia you can have like
like you know lower range but you can
have really really fast so yeah Neil
atrial be clear just to be a little more
complete here so uh the Greek word
tachus means speed or Swift and that's
where you get tachometer from it and
tachon hypothetical particles that exist
traveling faster than light and now the
medical folks you're all into the Greek
and Latin roots there this I presume
it's the same roote for the word I die
faster than
light how about that sorry death I beat
your death faster than lik this right
you can't kill me I killed myself killed
myself I won I outran death yeah
congratulations so Ley are there are
there top
five misunderstood things about the
heart that that run around the public I
mean I could say the top five things M
People misunderstand about space first
they think that you can hear explosions
in space because every movie that right
you know I can go down I got my list so
what's your list of things that people
think is true but are but not yeah I'll
put this under say the top five I mean
there's so many I can share but the top
five human heart facts and or myths uh
first of all let me start off with that
I'll say that most heart attacks I don't
think people know this most heart
attacks happen on a Monday morning um
and so why why is that it turns out that
Mondays cause more stress than other
days for most people and stress hormones
are the highest in the morning and both
of these combined increase blood
pressure increase heart rate and stress
hormones they break off a piece of
plaque leads to blocking of the vessel
and a heart attack Chuck I need you to
sing here rainy days and Monday
always
yeah I just call
out there's another there is another Pop
Song by an Irish manand called the
Boomtown Rats called I Don't Like
Mondays oh Bob Goff right Gary thank you
li good
knowledge thank you look at
that mic drop oh thank you um another
one of my favorite uh like top five kind
of human heart facts or Miss men and
women have different heart attack
symptoms people think oh women to have
that oh crushing chest chest pain that's
actually not true women present somewhat
differently often more kind of benign
subtle things that get missed some
nausea some difficulty breathing sweats
um so I think that's important for women
to recognize that but especially doctors
when they present in the emergency
department don't just brush it off as
heartburn or they're they have anxiety
make do the proper testing get a proper
history um and by the way so we already
talked about a broken heart heart well a
broken heart can feel like a heart
attack because they have a sudden
intense feelings of sadness or grief
which can mimic our heart attack uh with
symptoms with chest pain and a shortness
of breath and why is that because those
stress hormones and the treatment for
that for a broken heart is just getting
rest another one of my favorite myths so
I'm reminded wait wait so Aristotle
would famously infamously declared that
the source of our feelings are in our
heart so he was partially right there in
this case yeah partially but it's it's
in the brain but
yes I'm a cheater's right but he's not
right right it's a part of your heart
that's in your brain there you go Chuck
said it right MD he's got it oh man yeah
well can I you're gonna like this myth
um sneezing does not stop your heart or
it doesn't make you your heart skip a
beat the heart May temporarily change
Rhythm but the heart only stops during a
cardiac arrest and lastly I like want to
want to share that laughing is good for
the heart blood vessels relax when you
laugh and then at least 20% more blood
going through your body so your heart
doesn't have to work as hard so some in
the middle of a heart attack wey to
bring Chuck along and tell them jokes
there you go save them oh no that has
surely killed them
no another really kind of cool heart
fact did you know that there's 60,000
miles of blood vessels in your heart and
if one of those blood vessels is damaged
your heart has to work even harder and
just for reference Neil is gonna love
this the circumference of the earth is
about say almost 25,000 miles you'd have
to take three trips around the earth to
have the equal the length of blood
vessels I thought that was kind of cool
okay so so I I once tweeted that if you
take all the the the veins capillaries
and arteries out of a body and string
them end to end that the person would
die that's my
contribution okay that's just what we
are so Gary you still thinking about
coid here what's what's up yeah I'm kind
of Trapped in my coid bubble but if we
think back Dr to that period That's Just
recent lots of different things entered
into our minds space as to what could be
happening what was happening what this
could do and what that could do the
causes and effects of things and there
was there was very little you know what
these are the facts so was it an
external thing was it an internal thing
was coid going to give us a heart attack
was the vaccine going to do some damage
that we couldn't tell you know because
no one had been there yet what are the
actual facts going forward as we know
now that were real and not fantasy of
some conspiracy so really great question
uh Gary so let me try to unpack this so
let's let's go back to early 2020 if not
even late 2019 when we were starting to
learn about this SARS K2 this novel
Corona virus so remember so what makes
it novel why where does that word come
from in this it it means honestly Neil
the medical scientific Community had
never seen this particular virus before
we've seen the first SARS uh Corona
virus that caused SARS um but but we've
never seen this version that's what
novel means it's new on the scene
exactly that's exactly what that means
and what we discovered day by day as the
remember we didn't even call it Co in
the beginning we called it the Corona
virus right um we learned slowly but
surely this is not your typical
respiratory virus it it it was attacking
all these different organ systems
compared to say the common cold virus or
influ fluenza virus these viruses
strictly cause respiratory symptoms and
to your point Gary we soon discovered
that SARS K2 it it attacked the brain it
caused neurologic symptoms caused GI
symptoms and it caused cardiovascular or
heart symptoms people were getting myo
um myocarditis cardiomyopathies all
these heart problems clots um they're
still trying to understand why but we
studies now are are suggesting an
indicating that SARS kobe2 and Co 19
it's not even so much an infection as it
really is like an immunologic problem um
and to your point Gary so back when
Demar Hamlin the NFL player underwent a
a cardiac arrest he's thankfully alive
but I when I posted a video about his
cardiac arrest and he was making the
different explanations why it happened
um so many people responded and thought
um incorrect ly that the SAR the coid
vaccine on Brewster caused his cardiac
arrest and let me just say the studies
are very clear that coid 19 or the SARS
K2 virus has been shown to cause cardiac
problems but not the vaccines just as a
reminder that vaccines they are
medications that are designed for all
people and so they undergo perhaps the
most rigorous testing more than any
other medication are there some side
effects they're yes they're usually
minor um but it it is not Cardiac Arrest
is really not not one of them well you
you mentioned something I I have to
emphasize it because I haven't heard it
put so succinctly that if I'm developing
a if I'm big Pharma or any kind of
pharmer and I'm developing a medicine
for a particular ailment then I'm going
to test it on people that have that
ailment and maybe a few others just for
control but I don't have to test on
everyone because it's only targeting an
ailment that I'm trying to see if I can
cure a vaccine obviously when we if
we're reaching for herd immunity that
goes into everyone essentially everyone
and so you would expect vaccine trials
to involve mifold more people in the
testing of it than any other kind of
drug is that a fair exposition of what
you just said yeah and I I'm glad you
emphasize it again in fact I'm going to
reemphasize your emphasis of what I st
because and I'm doing this Neil because
as you all know the antivaccine movement
and vaccine skepticism has really
Skyrocket it was already on the rise
before coid it is just skyrocketed and
this is a major public health problem
because we're
seeing Rises epidemics are little In
Pockets of communities of measles of
polio and to your point Neil vaccines
think about childhood vaccines vaccines
that we all got as babies
to prevent
diptheria prevent not to treat prevent
getting tetanus polio diptheria um these
were designed uh to make sure they were
safe for babies so that we can then all
grow up to be healthy adults and I think
I'm old enough to have had a small poox
vaccination I think that's what and I'm
Canadian so I got small pox in Canada
yeah sry the vaccine not the say wow I'm
not going to Canada
now so doc up tailing on what you just
said the vaccine
actually prevent because you just said
some prevent or do they actually lessen
symptoms and keep you out of the
hospital yeah that's a great great way
of actually structuring that that this
issue of vaccines and to address the
confusion that the public has so
historically all these childhood
vaccines they were mostly designed to
prevent you from getting the disease
diptheria tetanus pertusus polio the
coid vaccines however that were
developed in the last couple of years
there's confusion because it doesn't
necessarily prevent you from getting the
disease the coid vaccines were designed
to do three things and they do them very
well one is to reduce the severity of
disease reduce hospitalizations and
reduce deaths unfortunately it wasn't
messaged necessarily that way in the
beginning by just we think we thought of
it as a as another vaccine where then
you'll never get it again you'll lot of
the push back from the public was well I
got the vaccine I still got coid it
wasn't designed to prevent you from
getting coid it was designed to really
prevent you from getting severely sick
and dying getting hospit and dying so
that's same as influenza too I mean this
is the deal with influenza that many
people uh say well I don't I don't need
it because you know it's I I you know
and and let me tell you you get the flu
once for real yeah I I got it once in my
life for real and I've never not gotten
vaccinated again can I tell you Chuck I
just interviewed a rapper IC te because
he's promoting the flu vaccine he wants
he wants to tell his story and because
and so the flu vaccine to your point Che
will it mean you'll never get the flu no
but it's significantly reduces your risk
of getting the flu and as somebody who
rotated through the Duke uh ICU I
remember seeing a 35y old man otherwise
completely healthy guy he was on what's
called an ECMO machine which is like a
more advanced like that ventilator and I
asked the fellow my ICU fellow hey what
what's what's his deal and he said oh he
has the flu this is a guy that nearly
died from influenza people forget that
still 35,000 people a year people still
just influenza vaccines work people get
the vaccine all right and don't write
please okay if you don't want to do it
that's you okay that's you but it's
science this is a science show what we
saying vetted information it is
empirical it has been proved and so when
we say it we're not telling you to do
anything we're giving you the
information that's all we're doing so
don't write and I don't want to hear
about call 911 Chuck a doctor I'm doct
you guys are getting all political look
at you on Star Talk getting all it's not
political it's science you're political
you're political it's the fact all right
I'm done all right good um I'm glad you
I'm glad you vented and moving into
thickening of ventricle walls doctor
this is is if I'm wrong correct me
please isn't this one of the side
effects of getting something like coid
now if that's the case can you rehab out
of that unlike if you got sort of
hypertropic cardiopathy which it
thickens and it stays thick does this
yeah with coid and it thickens it can be
rehabbed out or is it going to stay
thick yeah I'm glad we're talking about
heart inflammation and not anger
management no okay yeah Gary thanks for
clarifying so heart inflammation uh
cardiomyopathy can it be reversed
through treatment so the answer is
actually yes first of all heart
inflammation is rare right um it it
occurs post injury or after an infection
mild cases don't even need treatment um
so treatment depends on the type of
inflammation and the underlying cause
and the most common types are
endocarditis myocarditis pericarditis
and the treatment would be antibiotics
steroids
antifungals
antifungals yeah because the fungus can
cause um uh can cause cardiomyopathies
and heart inflammation so so yeah that's
the good news now see I have something
called left ventricular hypertrophy so
that's a thickening of the wall but my
cardiologist said that that I I mean he
gave me some medication to soften my
heartbeat but he was like I said so how
do we unthicken the wall and he said
it's a different kind of muscle it
doesn't work that way so LV what you're
describing Chuck is LVH we use that the
term very commonly our left ventrical
hypertrophy so that's different from say
like HCM or hypertrophic cardiomyopathy
so that's a different often that there's
a genetic causes for that but what
you're describing Chuck is actually very
common and and that's because one of the
most common causes for LVH is actually
hypertension or high I have yeah y
that's exactly what did it yep exactly
and valve disease particularly the um um
aortic valve and mital valve disease uh
when you get any kind of blockage or
impairment of that that valve that left
ventricle has to pump even harder which
is why that heart muscle gets bigger and
bigger the good news is that these are
treatable so these this is a reversible
type of LVH right so treat the high
blood pressure treat the valve a reverse
the valve disease you can actually um
treat and manage the LBH and reverse It
Go hope die after all there is hope
there is
hope of all the people who die of heart
disease what percentage of them does it
come from uh A congenital condition that
they just were uh cheating time their
entire life so for example I'm old
enough to remember the 19 1970s where
jogging and running became a craze
basically for the first time there were
books on it there was a guy named Jim
fix who was a big running Enthusiast he
was interviewed everywhere and he wrote
a book a best-selling book and he
dropped dead of a heart attack and only
then did we learn his sorry he dropped
like in his 40s or 50s that his father
had heart disease died very young and
maybe he cheated time
many years Beyond his due date at for
even having died young so I I just I'm
just asking uh what percentage of that
is it and I didn't realize that
congenital heart disease is as common as
it sounds like it
is so look the vast majority of people
who die of heart disease really die are
of heart attacks and strokes uh from
preventable uh
causes so let to be really clear about
that okay the vast majority especially
today it's lifestyle modification which
can prevent that or significantly reduce
your risk well you're talking about Neil
with the congenital heart disease it's
actually pretty rare are there could it
be could there be more cases of that if
we did our testing for it sure but but
the good news is that if you're not
getting diagnosed with until much later
in life that's actually the good kind of
congenital heart disease to get most of
them the babies that are getting and we
now have in utero um cases where you can
um you know because because remember the
cardiac development Ends by week eight
of gestation so but and we now have
great fetal technology um Imaging so we
can detect in utero if a person if a
fetus is going to have a congenital
heart defect most conal heart defects so
that's it's rare many are are treatable
in utero uh and and once a baby is born
so neonatal Cardiology there's amazing
cardiac surgery um advancements in that
regard when when you said about you know
these genetic M mutations that
predispose you to cardiac
events and you say screen them are you
always looking for the same Flags or do
these things change and are tricky so so
there are several genes that are
involved in ious ways some can increase
your risk for arrhythmias um some can
increase your risk for coronary artery
disease like it's say in my dad's case
I'm without doing any testing I almost
promise you he had a strong family
history and genetic history so there's a
lot of genes that that are involved I
think we're finding more and more um
gene therapy is an exciting area to be
honest it it has the field of Cardiology
has not really um utilized gene therapy
as much as say other fields like card um
pardon me oncology um so but there are
um exciting advancements in that when
you say gene therapy I guess I don't
really know what that is are you going
in and nip tucking the gene sequence or
are you learning about the gene defects
and then you give support So gene
therapy again there's different ways um
let's use the example Cleveland Clinic
infused the first gene therapy for
hypertrophic cardiomyopathy and this
actually just came out in October uh
which we're still October and it's based
on this meios binding protein C3 gene
mutation which is actually the most
common genetic cause of ah HCM so what
they're doing actually is kind of going
in and replacing or repairing that Gene
again it depends on what the genetic
mutation is sometimes you just have to
just just rectify the mutation other
times you there's no protein at all so
you just have to replace the gene so it
depends on the on the mutation so that's
all gene therapy that you're describing
correct corre and if you make that
change will their
offspring no longer be susceptible do
they pass that Gene
edit edited Gene C couple of ways to
answer that so it depends on at what
stage they if they've already had kids
then obviously they're going to pass on
that same defective Gene right um if it
was done before early on then at that
point if the gene is repaired they'll
just pass on the healthy genan so oh man
well we need to make gene therapy the
order of the day for everything
everything everything gez it's damn
expensive Chuck that we need a lot more
research in it again the field of
oncology is really on top of this and
other other areas Cardiology
surprisingly not as much but that said
there's so much research behind
Cardiology because it's the leading
cause of death so I think there's going
to be exciting stuff coming out so now
i' you know um I've seen where the there
are doctors that say certain medications
they use the genes to your genetic
makeup to tailor certain medications to
your disease is is that part of gene
therapy or is that just a treatment
option yeah you guys are familiar with
like um what is it uh ancestry and
what's that the one two three the
something 23 and me let me just say that
the true medical opinion where that's
concerned um for of all really don't go
by those those tests I mean don't don't
use that to make medical decision-making
doctors Specialists we don't really
utilize that if you are it depends on
the patient Chuck it depends on the on
their history and what the actual
clinical indication is will do
appropriate genetic testing like say for
colon cancer you know um Chadwick
Boseman died in his 40s which is really
young to die of colon cancer but if you
have a strong family history then yeah
or braa um you know if you have a strong
family history of like ovarian breast
cancers then yes that will prompt us to
test you for these genes Angel Jolie had
the broag gene is that correct that's
exactly right preemptively had the
double masectomy prompted her to exactly
uh proac get the um uh prophylactically
get the uh double mastectomy because she
knew based on genetic testing that she
was at very high risk remember her
mother died of shoot is either ovarian
or breast cancer so she so so but I got
to tell you Chuck genetic testing is
very expensive A and B it's mostly still
unavailable so that's why we don't it's
not like for high blood you know get
screened for high blood pressure that's
a very simple and cheap screening
Technique we just don't have that really
for most conditions but doctor we're
dealing with the number one killer I
mean if this if this number one killer
were an individual a person of interest
there'd be a manh hunt and then some
right so are we talking about financing
are we talking about research dollars
here because if it we understand that
the need the need to for it to go into
oncology is most definitely there but
surely if it's number one and it's been
number one for some time now surely this
has to be dollars well
spent yeah so let me tell you I'm really
glad you brought that up and this is
where I'm G I might get a little angry
and frustrated with the system okay get
angry I'm gonna need anger management
right help now is the anger management
all right
we're g to do a whole show just on a
management man gez um no but my
frustration lies in to your point Gary
yes it Still Remains the leading cause
of death uh in this country and globally
but here's the thing we know how to fix
it we know how to prevent it we don't
need more research Gary in this
particular area we know it's to start
happening and why I I'll focus on the
United States because in this country we
don't invest in prevention we don't
invest in what we already know we don't
help the the communities that are real
that are marginalized that are at most
risk we aren't targeting those people
those communities we aren't telling them
hey if you just do X Y and Z and this is
how we're going to help you do it you're
gonna live a longer and healthier life
that's where the focus needs to be a
prevent profit structure I disagree I
disagree go ahead Neil bring it on oh
him up put him up okay I think in the
future you should be able to I should be
able to take a pill or something so that
I don't have to change my habits and I
still don't get heart disease that's the
typical Western approach right in this
country we want a pill for everything
right I want I want to eat all the
cholesterol I want right I want to sit
on a couch I want to be overweight and
still not di that's the solution that's
how I feel hey man I made a bacon and
large sandwich the other
day I went back and made another one
just took a pill and I'm fine and then a
donut and ice cream for dessert right
right right on the couch right you don't
even leave the couch yeah so there's
this idea of oh just give me a pill
doc lose weight I don't want to eat
healthy yeah that's a very Western
mentality right and I'm from West
so like there's something wrong with the
West that's and and guess what uh Neil
this is why we're dying this is why
heart disease is killing us look I just
came back from Denmark and Poland at the
end of the summer I was doing some
speaking some vacation and let me tell
you they they they have especially in
Denmark and in the in the Nordic Nations
they have a really healthy outcomes and
they live healthier lives they are
active they live healthy they also not
coincidentally have universal healthcare
um so all that's good but they also
don't have uh the most delicious food so
come on let's let's just be honest okay
like you're not gonna find that Pro
you're not gonna find that same outcome
in Italy okay you can go to Poland and
Denmark you G but but yeah I'm pretty
sure theyan restaurants in Copenhagen
really pretty sure I'm not gonna hit I
actually dined at NoMa one of the best
restaurants in the world but denark yeah
CH doesn't know about that the number
one rank restaurant in the world right
now is in oh they bought that ranking
and yes I know about them they bought
that ranking and you know it that's the
reason I went to Denmark because I got
invited I was a pandemic hero so I was
invited by no I was very honored but
what can I tell you Chuck you're right
Greece Italy they are known for their
Cuisine but they are also known for
having very active lifestyle and eating
healthier ingredients their Pizza and
Pasta made with much more healthier
ingredients so look in that it's not
processed and you're right but now wait
a bit did you just sparked this in me
one of the uh Chief um proponents of
long life is community and friendship
and what you find in those two
communities that you just mentioned is
tight relationships where people have
lifelong Companions and Friends what's
that do to the heart is that part of it
absolutely I'm so glad you mentioned
that a common motto in my field uh of
you know the opposite of addiction isn't
sobriety it's connection and what have
we seen in the last six months or so us
surgeon general's report loneliness is
the new epidemic um drug overs the
skyrocketed this is all connected
because social connections have been
disrupted uh all these connections human
beings the most introverted human being
still needs craves some type of
connection and human interaction all all
of this believe it or not is still heart
healthy because indirectly it'll reduce
your stress hormones it'll re normalize
your blood pressure your heart rate
which remember are all risk factors for
heart disease and let's not omit the
fact that if you have now a close friend
they'll say dude you're not eating
healthy these forces operating back on
you or friend that say hey Chuck man
you're getting a little too angry for me
right so you to say that right yeah so
Lippy where can we find
people can reach me on like Twitter or X
Lippy Roy Instagram and l i p i Roy uh
correct and then and Instagram and Tik
Tok Lippy Roy MD and I launched my new
speaking company sitam Med that's s t m
d llc.com so reach out anytime wow okay
so you're getting out there then I'm
trying my YouTube hell show Health humor
and Harmony we like the humor part
especially I trust me I know yeah
Delight to have you back on Star Talk
thanks for for your time and your
expertise thank you Neil a pleasure
being here all right Chuck and Gary
always good to have you guys Neil
degrass Tyson here your a personal
astrophysicist as always keep looking
[Music]
up